quelques questions sur son état de santé
une piqûre et deux secondes l'analyse de
sang Yoann profite de la 9e édition du
forum santé qui se tient à l'espace
Saint-Quentin pour tester son taux de
glycémie vous avez 1,35 g par les 200
donc au niveau de votre glycémie mais
comme vous venez de voir c'est normal
parce qu'ils sont un peu plus élevé donc
voilà vous voyez la normale entre 1 et
c'est un 26 donc vous avez peur le
diabète et la deuxième cause de maladies
cardiovasculaires en France une maladie
ravageuse qui est aussi une maladie
silencieuse 700 000 personnes seraient
atteintes sans même le savoir ça permet
d'être en bonne santé de savoir son état
actuel de santé si on est malade de se
faire soigner et
ça te rassure
avoir une réponse à ce qu'on peut se
poser comme question
dépistage donc mais aussi rencontre et
ateliers sont proposés par une vingtaine
d'associations l'occasion d'aborder tous
les thèmes de santé publique
alimentation hygiène et Addictologie on
a tendance à tout de suite penser aux
drogues dures à la cocaïne à l'héroïne
mais on oublie que le tabac l'alcool
fond beaucoup de ravages en France sur
le secteur en tout cas de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines les jeunes que
nous on rencontre c'est surtout le tabac
l'alcool et le cannabis qui qui sont
consommés pour faire le point sur sa
consommation cet appareil permet de
mesurer son taux de monoxyde de carbone
je m'y suis donc essayé selon ce test on
voit que le voyant est orange vous êtes
un taux de neuf donc je dirais que vous
êtes une fumeuse occasionnelle selon le
test
c'est le cas merci
et si vous aussi vous voulez vous faire
dépister rendez-vous à l'espace
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines au Forum de la
santé jusqu'au 8 juin